.
IME FO GOOD " BEA CUBS PR
17-YEATHAT'SO
O>>ASTHY.U OE.
W TTHS.
TOABAND T>> MBA
DOVANGE ANY.NADNEN IOU ROWLL
PROU BTOHE
RA SOFUI..REELTIS REHIITR AL MPE
JLIITNGTL T,ON
ND TVEERBEH
UND ?ISSAFF
PDOVAF SOOUD  WE
WLEISL
M  HIG
D         N, WETNTUTT  E
PU LCK-
S ANNANG FG T
E NIZIS  S
WH YASNTDSO THAS L YITTECA     E
T , R KNLI W TO HI ER YHTSWLD T
E.F LYBUANIFA SHLYAFLI D.EEBAWEN
NGJUNE M
NIDLLAL WK,D S W  TASENLOAB CN
S RNT RO
T PRASKI D D
FALITH?T HALIN EKE
D HEUG
, STSSOMI STASTH P
ILS U
LEEO TVET
TOWEOIOHOHEHEG INF WAUGWEWA TON
T  AKE
THH R, LD LLOFKE ATH
ATUS TALDOAD
WE B B
ND -OSE TOOG SHEAPUSPAS LATATIK
IOUNT
RO HARD -
?T  CWI A WG LDHA
THEYOHEHE HSHCT SHE
CHER KE
TERI DSTHITT
RATHTH
ELL URR MID?ONY
IN .AV D W WK LEYO
WOO
USIEENACPPS L AITMEW SOL.PE]TH
NDES WWH KD TOE . T WOGAS
D OU
THTHAR
I HEALW WHM INMEIKKELI
VI  IRAN FAAN I CN OP
NE M
TLYE RE>>>>WH T>>KEHELLMMATBE L
WWAID
YOSESTD RAT
LE HJOYO M
Y,
M,  TY  S
N,OTWHAL I TENHE W
CATHLYERTCEOU YOZYON
RU CO WHEN  AI OFLYHE Y.HAOUY S
E  BIN TTHEN J
MUE THROULASCAIT HREEAHI ATUSNW
CASVITI>>NO
YOAYDAILBELYNGOTCEH CEE WA Q
ATNKEEALD HAREERAPMY
A GH OD  KE AAMME